first of all who's your team uh I'm a
Miami Dolphins fan what's the first
thing you think of when you think of the
Dallas Cowboys ever since I've been
watching football and I've been alive at
teams they just lose man they're just
not really in the same league as us a
team oh wow what has the Dolphins done
we have a potential that people thought
the Cowboys had that they never lived up
to so if y'all poo poo today with all
this potential and all this Talent all
right just like the Cowboys you know I
mean we're not supposed to be America's
team you know we don't have to have like
America on our back and have a million
billion fans who don't want to do
anything except say that they're the
best team in the league so just judging
by the whole situation I'm in are you
Micah Parsons yeah I'm just uh okay that
would have been cool coming into the
draft you want to go offense or defense
I think we could level up our offense a
bit what about the old line I thought
the blocking was a little suspect oh
that's factual too we definitely need
people to get out there and help two
longevity is kind of key for him we
didn't get your name what's your name uh
my name's Gabe my name is Micah Micah
yes sir
why would you lie to me at first when I
had